to my colleagues to follow me to follow
me across the aisle to the republican
side of the chamber
so that we could blend in
so that we could blend in for i felt
that the insurrectionists who were
trying to break down the doors
right here would spare us
if they simply mistook us for
republicans
but within moments i recognized that
blending
in was not an option available
to my colleagues of color
so i'm here tonight to say to my
brothers and sisters in congress
and all around our country i'm sorry i'm
sorry
for i had never understood really
understood
what privilege really means
it took a violent mob of
insurrectionists
and a lightning bolt moment in this very
room
but now i know believe me i really
know
that was congressman dean phillips of
minnesota speaking there on the house
floor pretty powerfully about
uh his memories of january the 6th
february the 6th this saturday will mark
one month
since the ransacking of the united
states capital and we've learned many of
the perpetrators carried guns and
ammunition
enough ammo according to huffpost to
shoot everyone in congress
five times now we're also learning that
january had the third highest gun sales
of any month in american history more
than two million
firearms were bought according to
background check data analyzed by the
washington post
last month's gun sales were exceeded
only by june and july 2020
when republicans and the gun lobby
frightened white americans into
believing that they were being
threatened by antifa and black lives
matter protesters
perversely another kind of event in
america always leads to a spike in gun
sales
whenever a tragic mass shooting shocks
the entire nation like after the
sandy hook killings in 2012 second
amendment
men and women began panic buying
convinced that their homes will be
raided by
jack-booted thugs from the federal
government doing the bidding of leftist
gun grabbers
which brings us to another milestone
date coming up this month
february 14th that will mark three years
since a mentally disturbed 18 year old
took an ar-15 style semi-automatic rifle
to marjory stoneman douglas high school
in parkland florida and used it to
murder 17
students and teachers many of the high
school students who survived that
rampage have since campaigned
for popular gun reforms like universal
background checks
and higher age cut offs for purchases
they also organized a march for our
lives
one of the largest protests in american
history but along the way those
survivors have experienced a second kind
of victimization
some right-wing media personalities
gained fame by claiming the parkland
attack was a false flag
and the kids were professional crisis
actors paid by who else
george soros others on the right
attacked them as woke
virtue signaling leftists looking for
fortune and glory
and one fringe character who would go on
to be a republican congresswoman
pursued parkland survivor david hogg to
yell at him on the street in 2019.
we were protected by with security
guards with guns
there would be no mass shootings at
school you know that
the best way to stop a bad guy is with a
good guy with a gun
you're attacking our second amendment
and you have nothing to say
i'm a gun owner i'm an american citizen
and i have
nothing but this guy with his george
soros funding
and his major liberal funding has got
everything
i want you to think about that that's
where we are and he's a coward
yes that's now u.s representative
marjorie taylor green who in 2018
also posted on facebook that the
parkland shooting was a false flag
as we reported earlier on the show green
is trying to distance herself
from those acts the same kind of
unhinged revolting behavior that we've
seen before
uh in pro-gun extremists and in capital
insurrectionists
one congresswoman lucy mcbath whose own
son lost his life to gun violence
was unmoved by green's so-called mere
culpa today
this is about a member stalking the
children of tragedy
attacking survivors and threatening
violence
this is about a member denying the
existence
of dead children at sandy hook
elementary
and marjory stoneman douglas high school
it's a fair question three years ago the
parkland massacre shocked many americans
into wondering how to make a better
world
today a major political party is
elevating and defending wing nuts
who attack the parliament survivors and
belittle their experiences
is that better world still possible with
a gop like this
joining me to discuss this is cameron
caskey a survivor of the parkland
shooting
who co-founded the march for our lives
and is a gun control advocate
uh cameron thanks so much for coming on
the show i don't want to do this but i
have to start by asking about marjorie
taylor green and her
nutty hateful previous statements but
first for our viewers
here's her on the house floor today sort
of kind of walking them back have a
listen
you see school shootings are absolutely
real when i was 16 years old in 11th
grade
my school was a gun-free school zone and
one of my schoolmates brought
guns to school and took our entire
school hostage
and that happened right down the hall
from my classroom
i know the fear that david hogg had that
day i know the fear that these kids
have children are our future and they're
our most precious resource
i also want to tell you 9 11 absolutely
happened
well among other things cameron she
didn't apologize for calling your
classmate david hogg a coward
for saying he was paid by soros she
hasn't contacted i believe him or you to
apologize
what would you say to her if she called
you up well
you know the important thing to remember
with marjory taylor green is that
she's obsessed with the attention and i
think that it's important for us to kind
of
zoom out of marjory taylor green and
focus on the republican party
as a whole because again she loves this
she loves
the clicks she loves the views she's
been fundraising off of this
and you know this is really just one of
the best things that's ever happened to
her career because her base and the
republican party
loves this kind of stuff so you know i
i don't really want to talk about her
that much it's really the party as a
whole because
you know as many people have rightfully
said it's become the cue party
yeah and let's go beyond her and beyond
the republican party and let me ask you
this
there are plenty of people out there in
america partly thanks to social media
partly because
some people are just vile who pushed
this false flag
conspiracy theory the soros nonsense the
crisis actor
nonsense what's it been like for you
as a survivor especially coming up to
the anniversary to live through that to
see that to hear this
absolute offensive crazy nonsense
well i mean it's a reflection of where
our country's at right
now where misinformation has brought us
where you know organizations like
facebook have brought us
i mean facebook alone has fostered and
promoted this culture for so long
so it certainly isn't surprising to me
but you know it's it's
obviously dark it's obviously something
that is you know
not particularly easy on the soul but
again
you know these are elected officials
these are the people writing our laws
now unfortunately
marjorie taylor green has been removed
from her committees but
you know it's it's not really the
conspiracy theories that uh
that br that really you know are
heartbreaking it's the fact that this is
normal now
and that we have a politician having to
go
up in front of congress and say by the
way 911 happened which i think we
figured out
on 9 11 2001.
yeah and on that note about republican
politicians you
got a lot of attention yourself back in
the day for grilling your gop
home senator uh florida senator marco
rubio at a town hall after the shooting
i want to play a bit of that for our
viewers have a listen
so senator rubio can you tell me right
now that you will not accept a single
donation from the nra
i support the things that i have stood
for and fought for during my time
[Applause]
first of all the answer is people buy
into my agenda you could say
in the name of 17 people you cannot ask
the nra to keep their money out of your
campaign
i think in the name of 17 people i can
pledge to you that i will support any
law that will prevent a killer like this
no but i'm talking
about money
[Applause]
now cameron i know you've said in the
past that you felt you were maybe too
confrontational there you regretted not
having a
better dialogue but we've seen what the
republican party has become
since then just yesterday you tweeted
quote you've got two major parties the
democrats and the marjorie taylor green
parkland denial enablers
do you now think maybe you weren't tough
enough on rubio
well i was definitely focusing on the
wrong thing because you know nra money
is awful
but it's not the money where the nra's
influence comes it's their organizing
because they are they are really really
good
at distilling the people who will show
up at
the town hall meetings who will harass
people i mean
the base is so radicalized at this point
that that's where their strength comes
from what i wish i had said to senator
rubio at the time
was all of these excuses you're making
for why an assault weapons ban wouldn't
work are
completely nonsensical you know he talks
about loopholes if you've got a loophole
you plug it
he talks about uh the fact that if you
ban ar-15s
somebody will make another gun that's
identical okay great ban that one too
it's easy
so you know as a 17 year old i
wasn't exactly thinking from as much of
a legal perspective as i wish i had and
i'm certainly not
quite where i'd like to be yet but you
know i i
was talking about money and at the end
of the day it's not about money
it's about the fact that these people
get their votes
from those who have already been
radicalized and it's an entire party
that's beholden to the gun lobby the
same way
that you've got uh the you know the
military lobby
and the and the pharmaceutical lobby
it's all about
the organizing and it's all about these
where these people draw their voting
base
well first of all cameron don't do
yourself down i'm pretty sure you've
done more at the age of 17 than most of
us did when we were 17
although we wish you'd never had to go
through any of that let me ask you this
you mentioned it's not about money right
and i agree with you it's also a
cultural war there's very much culture
war
there are as many guns as people in the
u.s we hear that stat all the time
but we know that the vast majority of
those guns are owned by a small number
of people by a minority of americans
they just own lots of guns
individually uh the loudest most visible
gun owners and their lobby
uh they behave almost like a cult but
this is
you know this is the most important
thing i'm a religious fanatical
adherence
to what they think the second amendment
stands for to what they think guns
symbolize
i wonder can you break people out of
that cult
in the middle of a culture war have you
ever succeeded in getting someone to
come out of that kind of gun
obsessed cult well i think a lot of it
like you said it's it's about a culture
and it's about a
story that's being sold to these people
you know the gun lobby
is a storytelling organization and they
connect these weapons of war to the
concept of freedom
and as a lot of people who know what an
ar-15 is
would tell you an ar-15 is not a good
personal defense weapon it really isn't
it's made to kill people it's made to
kill a lot of people and it's made to
kill a lot of people quickly
so it's you know it's so much about the
narratives that are pushed in this
country
and it culture is really the only way
you're going to
fix that i know for a fact that the few
young conservatives i know because
you know a lot of young people are not
conservative because we're we're
thinking about our future uh a lot of
young conservatives
get pulled into radicalization because
of
culture wars they get pulled in because
they get annoyed by the concept of
cancel culture which
by the way was you know started by
conservative moms getting angry at the
simpsons
so you know that's not a liberal thing
but um it's
these things happen they they get driven
in by
media they get pulled into this by
youtube i mean
social media is where these people get
radicalized and it goes from people
listening to a podcast
to people wanting to dedicate all of
their free time to advocating advocating
for the interests
of the gun manufacturers so as much as
this is an important legal battle this
is also definitely
deeply ingrained in what we're teaching
our kids and also how we are
moderating the content that our kids are
consuming
and we've got 20 seconds left cameron
nra
imploding that bring a smile to your
face
uh it's objectively funny because you
know
this is an organization that likes to
tout itself around
uh very similar to how uh donald trump
behaved it was all about we are the
winners we're victorious
and ultimately if you are running an
organization that is fundamentally
criminal which
you know the documents have proven the
nra is you're gonna get your comeuppance
so i i have shared a laugh or two about
it but you know it's just
it's just a fact if you're if you're
gonna
cameron casca i wish we could speak
longer we're out of time thank you so
much for your time tonight
appreciate it
hi i'm mehdi hussain thanks for checking
out our channel on youtube you can see
more of the mehdi hassan show
by clicking on any of the videos on this
screen and make sure you subscribe
below to stay up to date on the day's
biggest stories
thank you for watching